trump has signed
into law a new 900 billion dollar
coronavirus relief and stimulus package
among its provisions
an extension of last spring's paycheck
protection program allowing another 284
billion
or some forgivable federally backed
loans for ailing
small businesses the initial program
overseen by the us government treasury
and small business administration
shepherds some 255 billion dollars to
more than 5 million recipients but was
fraud
with loopholes and liabilities that
raise countless issues throughout an
already complex
uh process and then at the same time for
unemployment the covert portion of the
bill revives a weekly pandemic jobless
benefit boost this time 300 through
march 14. it also extends
eviction protections adding a new rental
assistant fund
trump signing into this bill is two
thousand dollars plus the fact that
trump signed the stimulus into law make
take pressure off of republicans in both
the house and the senate to vote for the
boosted checks allowing them to stick to
their guns
on keeping the size of the relief
package under control the government is
now funded
for the next year crucial benefits
helping americans through the pandemic
are renewed and 600
checks will be on its way if the 2
dollar checks don't
pass thoughts um first of all i'm glad
they closed the loopholes i saw a thing
in here that they have a uh
a loss test so your business can't apply
for scoop number two unless you can show
that you had a
greater than 25 percent you know quarter
over quarter drop as regard a pen
the pandemic i think that's a good thing
because i agree there were some
businesses out there that just ran and
got the money yes
we read about sports teams that really
got the money four and a half million
right harvard business school
got harvard got eight and a half million
dollars and meanwhile but the lakers
gave the money back by the way like once
and that's
where it came out but meanwhile those
small restaurants and dry cleaners and
people that are in the neighborhood
around staples center downtown
you know we're having a hard time
getting five grand and the lakers did
but
lakers gave it back so when the
spotlight got shined they gave it back
but i like the fact that there's more
tests in now and it appears that this is
more friendly for the small business guy
to get in if you really had a loss and
it looks like it's harder
for the medium and large businesses just
to go fill out the form and get some
free capital
i like that part just when you didn't
think things could get any weirder you
have donald trump agreeing with
democrats
right pumping up the check value from
600 to 2000. this whole thing has been
bizarre
the senate still has to confirm this
thing right and they're they're ready to
break for the new year here pretty soon
but
good old bernie sanders is there a
bigger eagle maniac on the planet right
now than bernie sanders
i mean this guy's ego is so far but he's
got to be up there
it's up there here's what he said today
i will shut down the senate
i will force people to stay through who
are you you are one person from an
irrelevant state number one new
hampshire
basically irrelevant i mean who knows
anything about new hampshire
but he's out there saying he's going to
keep the city or vermont which looks
but you probably got it from you're
probably going to be i used to live in
new england that's a that's a big
mistake
all the small states look alike but you
know i'm in favor of anything that's
going to help the economy i'm in favor
of anything that's going to help small
businesses
if this also just shines a microscope on
what's going on in dc this bill was 6
000 pages long
who has a chance to actually read 6 000
pages of this legislation
all the pork that they try to jam in
this this thing is disgusting
but if it helps businesses if it helps
americans if it helps the economy i am
behind it i like the fact that trump
fought for a little bit more money
because 600 bucks really isn't that much
if you're gonna if you're gonna like
sign off on a bill of this magnitude
have a little bit more money going to
american citizens i think it's all is
okay
uh and i just hope there's less fraud
because when that first bill came out
there was so much fraud so many people
taking advantage of it i hope that they
found a way to shut that down
what is this going to do to the economy
i'll leave it up to you to answer that
one what is it going to do
it's going to give people a little bit
more confidence maybe hope maybe having
a little
thought that they can pay some more
bills maybe inject more money into the
economy i would imagine it will have
some sort of short short term effect
yeah i think it's going to be a little
lift going into first quarter
absolutely i think january we're going
to see some you know
those little stats that come out cost
goes up a little bit you know
i i think the average joe that is able
to get a check is
going to be able to do a little bit and
i think it's going to be a little
short-term pop i think the
the wall street reaction will be greater
than the real impact on the average guy
the wall street rio tell me what you
mean by that i think the market will be
up
more than the actual change and
and the lift and the help that we gave
to the average citizen got it so the
rich will get richer than the poor will
get a little richer
you're saying the rich is going to
benefit from this more than the poorest
uh yeah absolutely or the ownership
class that's owning
can you impact that what why is that
because the market's going to react and
the value of the assets are going to go
up for the people that already own those
assets and don't and
you know and make more money and didn't
need that extra thousand dollars and
we're ineligible to it and the little
guy on the corner
is going to get a thousand dollars and
it's going to be thanks that helps me a
little bit meanwhile he's got another
eight thousand dollar in credit card
debt and everything he's gone through
you know it's you know that that's the
part that this that kind of
fries me a little bit is we we never do
enough for
the citizen that's down at the end of it
and paid in my opinion
paycheck protection completely missed it
what you know paycheck protection should
meant if you prove you have no layoffs
and you prove what your um payroll is
we'll pay
x for a given amount of time and they
did that weird thing where they would
give you some
and then maybe we forgive it maybe we
don't forgive it and it just seemed like
that the little guy didn't get enough so
my opinion is
did they do better this time yeah but
i'm not cheering about it i think the
little guy still needs a little more
help
who wins here democrats or republicans
probably the democrats will spin it in a
way that they got trump to
you know come over on their side a
little bit more i don't know if i don't
look at this
and see that there's one clear winner
okay i think if you took a poll in the
street
the average the election's over except
georgia but the average person on the
street
i don't think is going to give a passing
grade to his government on this
does this regardless of how they voted
so right now is it fair to say that the
main thing that matters right now when
it comes down to politics is one state
11 million people right georgia's
numbers
does this influence anything there like
is this something where trump's going to
go and say
republicans got the deal done this is
why dot dot dot
dot and the democrats wanted to only
give 600 and send the other money to
all these special interest groups and
other countries and we got it done to
get the money in the american people
you think that's going to create some
motivation for people to say
you know what republicans got this done
this is the last weekend
you're going to see those comments and
more there's going to be all kinds of
those claims
i think you're on it you're going to see
all kinds of those claims made in the
last weekend
we're not going to see him in the rest
of the us but on tv radio
the the georgia voters going to get
bombed by people taking credit and
spending that
i don't think anybody's vote could be
swayed by that at this point in georgia
and i wish maybe 20 billion of this
this bill would go into making sure
there's no fraud in the election that
there's people looking at every one of
these votes
making sure that they're checking the
signatures and making sure that whatever
happens in georgia on january 5th is
legit
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye